my name is John I'm a private
investigator in Los Angeles and today
I'm privately investigating two truths
and a lie
let's find out who's lying I'm shaquita
Williams and I played soccer with actor
Boris Kodjoe
I'm Julian and I ran into Gerard Butler
at a restaurant in New York City I'm
Nate
I got stuck in an elevator with Seth
Rogen she tweeted let's talk soccer huh
yeah when was this
2017 we're at Atlanta and what's the
circumstance were you were you in a
league or it was like a corporate team
okay yeah I worked with a small
production company we were producing a
movie of his and his movie was in post I
got to work with him a bit and then he
joined us for a game of soccer team so
explain to me the corporate team I don't
what what corporation well it's a
corporate team we were in a corporation
we went through this company that likes
puts the games together and then they
match the companies to play against each
other so it was sort of sort of like a
league then yeah okay and they just let
this guy this hulking perfect specimen
of masculinity just walk onto a team
basically yeah we had an extra shirt so
when he got there we just like gave him
a team shirt huh all right so he played
in one game
yeah okay and and when you were on the
pitch with him what position were you in
I don't know what I did I just met on
the floor and try not to get hit by the
ball are you sure you weren't playing
dodge ball
where was the field oh it was indoor and
it was in a church this is an
interesting soccer game well the church
was Mike had a lot of building so I
guess the whatever company was that put
the games together would go and find
gyms Frist playing in that church had a
gym all right so we're in a church
gymnasium very specific about that Boris
just popped in for a game
[Music]
how many games did you play I played at
least like five or six games before I
quit okay yeah how often every Sunday
Sunday soccer at the church there's not
Church going on on Sundays
it was after church it was like late or
early evening time that's the time okay
all right I got a and I got a simmer on
this Boris Kodjoe story this is almost
too fantastical to believe Nate right
yeah okay elevator with Seth Rogen huh
okay when was that this was last year
under what circumstances where I was in
Burbank and I had an interview and we
just happened to be in the same building
and then our elevator broke down okay
what building I don't remember the name
of it I was in there just for like a
quick interview and I didn't do so poor
well all right we're at what with the
company or what yeah it was with the
production company okay what street was
the building on a brand Boulevard I
think I was like doing a bunch of them
at the time so it was just another one
that didn't go well
okay just him yeah it was just he and I
in the elevator was he wearing
he was like kind of formal I was in like
a suit and he was like just like worse
than I was I guess worse than you were
yeah okay I was like no he's just a slob
no he's just a total slob 'only kind of
pile of garbage is that what you're
telling me that's not what I'm saying
okay that's not what I'm saying yeah
okay can you describe that semi-formal
what does that mean he had like a nice
shirt on but it wasn't like buttoned or
tucked it's just like his clothes be
nice so what what's your first reaction
I was not in a great mood cuz I think I
really bombed the interview and then he
walked in and I was like is this Seth
Rogen I was really like thrown off by
that and then almost instantly after he
gets on it like crashes on the next
floor and so we both just kind of like
we hadn't said anything at that moment
and we look at each other and then we
kind of realize oh dang we're stuck in
here now that's when we started talking
so I mean like what you talked about
what What did he say he hid fun of my
clothes but you were dressed better than
him yeah but he didn't like my tie what
was on your tie it was just like a blue
tie but like the rest I was working like
it wearing a gray suit
look like a blue tie and he just kept
making fun of me for it okay I just
didn't like it so if this story is true
seth rogen finds himself in this extreme
circumstance and feels the need to
degrade the other person in the elevator
with them and then what's the resolution
here as soon as it broke down like the
lights got all weird and then a little
voice came from the elevator like a
little automated message and we just sat
in there for a while and then like after
like half hour or so he just came back
on and we got out all right
thanks Nate Julien talk to me yes I was
in New York City and with a friend of
mine
popped into a restaurant and when I
walked up to the the hosts table I
actually I thought George Butler was the
host so I asked him for a table for two
and he just laughed at me not in a real
rude way kind of thing just knew like I
didn't know who he was I guess or
whatever and then kind of walked away
that was the breadth of the Indian rest
of the Inc okay what was the restaurant
oh man I don't know this was a it wasn't
like a dive you kind of place it was one
of that had fancy cocktails and stuff
like in their in their menu okay what
kind of food they serve I would guess I
would call it just like modern American
I think I had like chicken and waffles
like kind of crunchy kind of didn't have
meal
okay what time of day was this early
afternoon like probably somewhere
between like new than two o'clock like
in that kind of timeframe what time of
year I was winter it was a not like the
dead of winter but it was cold I
remember okay remember noticing his
jacket he sat at a table like just a
couple tables away from us and I
remember noted like his jacket being
this like brown suede clearly very
expensive kind of kind of jacket and
what day was it hmm
it's probably a weekend who was he with
it was a table for four it was him and a
male friend and two female friends I
guess okay so when he sat down and you
sat down how close were you by by that
point probably he might have been about
like 15 feet away you know like it was
not like no next table but it was just a
couple tables that's pretty close though
I mean that'd be awkward after getting
one off by the guy to then be I don't
think he's peripheral I line yeah I mean
we definitely had what is here would you
say you ordered I think it was like it
taken waffles kind of thing okay what
did he get oh I don't know so what was
he doing at the maitre d table that or
at the I must just been asking a
question I don't know I liked it it was
he might have just been there what as we
walked up and you know the the host
I guess stepped away or something and
then so it was just I think a timing
thing and then who were you with my
friend Alyssa yeah okay what's her story
what's her deal uh college friend Alyssa
she sounds suspicious
alright well I've asked a lot of
questions I think it's about time I make
a decision here so I know you're an
actress and a model but you mentioned
you were producing in Atlanta so I get
the feeling oh maybe you're a producer
here at BuzzFeed post editing site still
counts down in Atlanta 2017 growing film
industry down there now moving on to
Nate Nate I believe is involved somewhat
in the animation game and so is seth
rogen I tried to dig into the geography
of where this meeting took place now
your your story is you are on so many
interviews you just can't remember where
any of them were in an elevator starts
making fun of you okay I buy that Julian
you're in New York Gerard Butler it's a
random celebrity I mean he's done some
good work I got nothing against the guy
now you know the thing was Julian it
doesn't remember the restaurant says
it's probably a weekend
everybody's got some good stuff I get
the feeling like Nate's story is true
you know I'm just gonna say that for the
time being I'm just gonna put that on
the shelf
I think Julian's lying about your art
Butler that's your final answer yeah I
am not lying about chard Butler I don't
believe it no none of it was true right
on a good job you fill in the details
and it sounded reasonable like I said
we're in LA so it's not it's not a
stretch of the imagination and you know
like I said my guess would be that's Oh
unbelievable it's got to be true
it's hard
[Music]